en el último vídeo introdujimos la idea
de que podemos representar funciones
periódicas por una serie de senos y
cosenos con pesos verdad y lo que voy a
hacer ahora es justamente empezar a
establecer las bases matemáticas para
que sea directo el cálculo de estos
coeficientes o pesos en la serie de
furia y verdad entonces lo primero que
quiero hacer es enfocarme en el
intervalo 0 2 y verdad porque este es
digamos un ciclo de nuestra función f
aunque en realidad date cuenta que
podríamos hacerlo en cualquier otro
intervalo de longitud 2 pi y además por
ejemplo si el periodo fuera otro
entonces lo haríamos sobre intervalos de
esa longitud verdad pero al menos así
con con el intervalo 0 2 pi las cuentas
son mucho más sencillas verdad así que
ahora vamos a establecer algunas
relaciones de integrales definidas de
funciones trigonométricas y vamos a
hacerlo un poquito más abajo muy bien
entonces la primera que vamos a ver es
que la integral de 0
de 0 a 2 pide la función seno de m t de
m t de t es igual a 0 muy bien esa será
la primera relación que veremos y esto
será cierto
para cualquier valor de m que sea un
número entero entonces vamos a poner
cualquier m entero y que no sea 0 verdad
entonces vamos a ponerle no nulo muy
bien entonces es para cualquier m entero
no nulo y esta integral que vamos a
calcular abajo es la integral de 0 a 2
pi del coseno de mt dt y esto también
será 0 para cualquier m entero no nulo y
en realidad puedes saltarte esta parte
oeste vídeos y los y das por hecho estas
dos estos dos resultados o si sabes cómo
demostrar que en efecto valen cero pero
esto es en realidad un muy buen repaso
de cálculo integral así que vamos a
hacerlo vamos a copiar lo aquí abajo
vamos a calcular la integral de cero
del seno de mt
dt muy bien y lo que vamos a hacer es
tratar de ver cuál es la anti derivada
de esta función y en realidad lo que
vamos a hacer es primero ver quién es la
derivada con respecto a t del coseno de
mt entonces si nosotros usamos la regla
de la cadena en realidad tendríamos la
derivada de m por teques
m por la derivada del coseno verdad que
sería menos seno de mt muy bien entonces
ésta sería la derivada y esto en
realidad si lo escribimos mejor sería
menos m por el seno del deporte entonces
si nos damos cuenta aquí necesitamos que
aparezca menos m
entonces para que aparezca podríamos
poner menos m y también dividir entre
menos m o multiplicar por menos uno
entre m de esta forma no estamos
cambiando el resultado de esta integral
verdad entonces lo que podemos ver es
que aquí
ya tenemos la anti derivada del coseno
de mt
entonces esto será igual esto será igual
a menos 1 entre m por la anti derivada
de menos m seno de emt que es coseno de
mt vamos a ponerlo con otro color
esto es coseno de mt y está arriba irá
evaluado desde 0 hasta 2 pi muy bien
entonces cuánto vale esto bueno
nuevamente tendremos menos 1 entre m por
el coseno de 2 p por m verdad o lo que
es lo mismo coseno de m por 2 - el
coseno de m por 0 que es coseno de 0
verdad entonces veamos cuánto vale cada
uno de estos el coste no de un múltiplo
de 2 para siempre vale 1 y el coseno de
0 también vale 1 así que toda esta parte
toda esta parte lo voy a poner con
azulito toda esta parte vale 0 y si 0 lo
multiplicamos por cualquier número entre
sigue siendo 0 y así es cómo obtenemos
que esté integral vale 0 como habíamos
dicho en un principio vamos a hacer lo
mismo o algo muy parecido con la
integral del de 0 a 2 pi del coseno de
mt dt muy bien y vamos a hacer algo muy
similar que antes vamos a multiplicar
por m aquí y dividir entre m afuera
verdad entonces esto será igual a 1
entre m por la anti derivada de esta
expresión verdad m por el coseno de mdt
pero nosotros podemos ver que eso es la
anti derivada perdón la anti derivada de
esta expresión es seno de un deporte de
verdad y esto irá evaluado de 0 a 2 y
muy bien entonces esto será igual
1 / m que multiplica a vamos a poner lo
mejor con el verde que ya teníamos que
multiplica al seno de 2 pi por m menos
el seno de 0 verdad entonces nuevamente
el seno de un múltiplo de dos pies cero
el seno de cero es cero y entonces toda
esta expresión que tenemos aquí vale
cero verdad que multiplicado por
cualquier otra cosa sigue siendo cero y
por lo tanto esta segunda relación que
teníamos aquí es cierta así que esta
será una buena base de donde partir
ahora vamos a hacer algunas integrales
un poco más complejas en los próximos
vídeos para que así sea directo el
encontrar coeficientes de furia con un
poquito de cálculo y manipulación
algebraica